Guten Abend, mein Name ist Kevda Gövdar. Ich bin die zuständige Eistin für Sie, bevor wir zu Ihren Bescheidern kommen, lassen Sie mich einfach Informationen über die notiert sind.
Ja, Frau Druchtig, ich kann es so lange nicht warten, ich habe Schmerzen, deswegen bin ich jetzt da, bitte machen Sie schnell.
Ich habe schon seit 2, 3 Stunden Schmerzen, das ist ganz, ganz schlimm, bitte, geben Sie mir irgendwas.
Wie heißen Sie bitte noch mal? Das ist aber ein komischer Name.
Kevda Gövdar.
Kevda Gövdar, ich weiß, was ist jetzt, was ist Vorname, was ist Ihr Nachname?
Ja, natürlich, Kevda ist mein Vorname und Gövdar sieht mein Nachname.
Gövdar, das ist aber ein komischer Name. Sie sehen aber nicht aus Wienweiler, oder?
Ja, natürlich, ich wohne in Wienweiler, aber ich komme aus der Türkei.
Auf der Türkei, ach je, dort, wo dieser große, große, naja, wie sagt man, große Putin lebt, ja?
Okay, naja, Frau Druchtig, ich habe Schmerzen, Schmerzen, ganz schnell.
Ja, okay, okay, okay, ich verstehe, ich verstehe, aber ich muss einfach Fragen stellen, okay?
Die können Sie aber später stellen, bitte, geben Sie mir irgendwas gegen die Schmerzen, das ist schlimm.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe, Sie haben Sorgen und Sie haben Schmerzen, aber ich muss diese Fragen stellen.
Frau Druchtig, vergessen Sie die Fragen, ich möchte etwas gegen meine Schmerzen haben, bitte.
Was für eine Beschwerden haben Sie immer?
Endlich kommt die Frage. Hier im Bauch, ganz rechts unten im Bauch habe ich Schmerzen, ganz kräftige.
Ganz unzündlich, okay. Warum haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ja, das hat vor ungefähr einer Stunde angefangen, ganz langsam, bis aber jetzt ganz heftig geworden.
Jetzt wird es wieder ganz schlimm, es kommt und geht und es wird immer schlimmer.
Okay, und?
Geben Sie mir etwas gegen die Schmerzen, das ist ja kaum aufzuhalten, ich ist ja fast schon bewusstlos.
Okay, haben Sie etwas eingenommen als Medikament?
Ich habe eine Aspirin genommen, aber eine Aspirin habe ich genommen, aber...
Wie viel Milligramm?
Ja, eine Tablette, diese Kopfschmerztablette halt.
Okay, 100 oder 500, okay.
Was machen Sie gegen Kopfschmerzen? Ich habe nicht drauf geschaut, ich weiß es nicht.
Okay, ich habe Ihre Bauchschmerzen auf einer Schmerzfälle von 1 bis 10.
Im Moment ganz stark, im Moment 10, im Moment 9 bis 10, ganz schlimm, bitte, geben Sie etwas gegen die Schmerzen.
Hören Sie mit den Fragen auf, es ist ja kaum aufzuhalten, ich werde gleich bewusstlos.
Okay, ich gebe Ihnen eine Schmerzmutter, okay?
Oh, bitte, bitte, bitte.
Okay, bitte schon.
Aber bitte nicht vergessen, ich habe eine Allergie gegen Novalgin, was wollen Sie mir geben?
Okay, nee, ich würde nicht Novalgin geben, andere Alergin oder Unfallschöchelbrechen.
Nein, nein, also nur Novalgin Allergin, ja.
Okay, okay.
Wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt?
Das wirkt sehr gut, was war das für ein Medikament, das ist schon besser geworden, aber die Schmerzen sind immer noch da, aber es ist schon viel besser, vielen Dank.
Okay, geil.
Jetzt muss ich ein paar Fragen stellen, guck mal.
Jetzt können Sie Ihre Fragen stellen.
Wie ist Ihr vor und nach nach?
Ja, ich schließe Sie, wie heim ich.
Mein Name ist Klaus Weichel.
Klaus Weichel.
Könnten Sie Ihr vor und nach Namen langsam umfügt, bestabieren?
Das sollten Sie doch wissen, Klaus, K, L, A, U, S.
Ja, genau.
Mein Nachname ist Weichel, Walter Emil, Ida, Caesar Heinrich, Emil Ludwig, Weichel.
Ludwig, ja, okay.
Hi Weichel, wie eigentlich?
Sie kennen meinen Namen nicht, Frau Doktor?
Ja, noch nicht.
Oh, das ist aber...
Ich bin doch der Oberbürgermeister von Kaiserslauter.
Ah, ja, okay.
Sie haben doch hier Freunde, die kennen mich, also müssen Sie mich auch kennen.
Ich bin neu, vielleicht, deswegen.
Ah, dann sei Ihnen Verziehen, aber einen Oberbürgermeister müssen Sie erkennen.
Okay, es freut mich, dass Sie uns lernen, Frau, ich heiße Weichel.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Noch sehr jung, Frau Doktor.
Okay, aber wie alt sind Sie?
Ach, das wollen Sie unbedingt wissen, ich bin 58 Jahre alt.
Okay, wann genau sind Sie geboren?
12. April 1963.
1963, okay.
Wie groß und wie viel sind Sie?
Ich bin ca. 1,85 m.
80, ja.
Und Wege 94 kg.
Okay. Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ja, Sie haben uns von gesagt, Oberbürgermeister.
Ich bin Oberbürgermeister der Stadt Kaiserslauter.
Und ansonsten bin ich...
Wie ist Ihr Familienstadt?
Ich bin schon heiratet, ich habe jetzt neu geheiratet vor 2 Jahren.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Oh ja, mehrere.
Ja, wie viel?
Ich habe 2 Töchter und einen Sohn.
Ja, sehr gut, einen Sohn.
Ja, Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben Bauchsmärkte in Bechten.
Ja, von der Stütte.
Ja, und Ihre Schmerzen haben flüssig aufgetreten.
Vor ungefähr eine Stunde.
Ja.
Und Sie haben ausgehend bekommen, aber ja, eingenommen.
Aber ja, nicht gleich war.
Und was noch?
Könnten Sie genau wagen oder zeigen,
wo Sie schmerzen am Tag sind?
Unterhalb, rechts unten.
Ja, rechts unten, aber das ist...
Genauer kann ich das nicht zeigen, das ist...
Man oben, man unten, dann strahlt es so ein bisschen auch in die Leiste.
Und das kommt manchmal so wellenartig.
Aber manchmal ist es auch eher stechend, ja, das ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, ich muss erbrechen.
Aber haben Sie noch nicht gebrauchen, ja?
Nein, nein.
Ich habe eine leichte Übelkeit.
Jetzt nach dem Medikament ist es auch besser geworden.
Okay.
Haben Sie schon einmal ähnliche Bescheiden?
Nein, das ist das erste Mal.
Okay.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Ihre Schmerzen würden Ihre Schmerzen im meisten Bereich ausgragen, ja?
Ja.
Okay.
Und sind Ihre Schmerzen auch von der meisten Zeit?
Nein, kann ich nicht sagen, das kam jetzt ganz plötzlich,
obwohl ich sowas vorher noch nie gehabt.
Okay.
Haben Sie FIFA oder fühlen Sie sich...
Ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Nein, okay.
Ja, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlösen?
Die Rennen?
Nein, nein, das war alles in Ordnung.
Ja, ich bin wegen der Prostata beim Uralom in Behandlung,
aber das ist alles in Ordnung gewesen.
Okay.
Haben Sie andere Bescheiden?
Nein, das ist auch schon...
Nein, das habe ich schon gesagt, aber ich habe jetzt nur einen hohen Blutdruck,
wo ich Medikamente nehme.
Ja.
Und sonst ist eigentlich alles in Ordnung.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Ich habe Bluthochdruck, auch seit circa acht Jahren.
Was nehmen Sie?
Ich nehme...
Was haben Sie auch zum Ramepris?
Im Maishe-douffillon.
Auch das weiß ich nicht.
Das ist so eine kleine, kleine, weise Runde,
aber ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Morgen einmal nehmen Sie...
Einmal morgens.
Okay.
Ich habe jetzt andere, oder leiten Sie an antarteklamische Erkrankungen
außer Bluthochdruck.
Ich meine, meine Zuckerkrankheit,
erhörst du Blutwerte weiter oder andere?
Ja, gut. Erhörte Blutwärtswerte habe ich wohl schon,
aber war jetzt wohl nicht so schlimm.
Ansonsten Diabetes habe ich jetzt nicht.
Ich bin regelmäßig bei der Kontrolle.
Ich bin ja der Bürgermeister,
ich werde ja immer regelmäßig durchsucht oder untersucht.
Und ich habe da jetzt eigentlich keine weiteren Beschwerden.
Okay, okay.
Das ist gut.
Sind Sie schon einmal Operexponsen?
Ja, ich hatte schon mal eine Operation gehabt.
Wegen der Gallenblase.
Da habe ich Gallenblasensteine gehabt und eine Entzündung.
Aber das liegt schon sehr lange zurück.
Okay.
Und wo die Gallenblase entleiden?
Ja, ja.
Von sehr langen Zeit, ja.
Ja, ja, das sind so 20 Jahre.
Ansonsten gibt es andere Operationen?
Ich hatte mal wegen dem Knie mal eine Untersuchung,
aber sonst ist da eigentlich nichts bekannt.
Keine Operationen bekannt.
Okay.
Sind Sie gegen Korrektoren hingeholt?
Ja, ja.
Ich habe schon 3 Mal die Info bekommen.
In Ihrer Familie gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen.
Ich meine vielleicht,
ich habe die Bürokraft, ich habe die Bürokraft weitergehalten.
Nein, nein.
Ist nichts bekannt, nein.
Ja, okay.
Ich muss erfassen, ich werde es da.
Okay.
Sie haben schon gesagt,
Sie haben keine Fieber.
Und schlafen Sie gut?
Normale Weise.
Auch bei den Sorgen, die wir im Moment haben,
schlafe ich natürlich nicht so gut, aber.
An sich schon, ja.
Okay.
Und leisen Sie Apotheosigkeit?
Nein, der Apotheos ist manchmal zu gut.
Ja.
Und während Ihres Schmerzen,
würden Sie etwas essen
oder trinken oder keine Apotheos.
Haben Sie das bemerkt?
Werden Sie Schmerzen?
Nein.
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme auf der Arbeit,
die Sie belasten oder im Leben?
Frau Doktor, Sie fragen Sachen,
natürlich habe ich große Probleme.
Natürlich mit den ganzen Parteien
oder den Politikern.
Ja.
Problemen habe ich genug.
Das kann schwierig sein.
Probleme gibt es genug.
Aber, ja,
Ja, ich ich kreise, haben Sie.
Natürlich jeden Tag.
Ja, jeden Tag.
Wir haben schon gesagt, Sie nehmen täglich eine Prise ein.
Amtlösen gibt es andere Medikamente,
Regen, Medikamente oder Regen, die Sie annehmen.
Nein, amtlösen sind mal so Schmerztabletten, aber mehr ist es nicht.
Schmerztableten sind die meinen Aspellen.
Ja.
Ja, das ist so.
Schauen Sie, Herr Weichel.
Ja.
Schlechtes Wundeln, aber ja.
Aber nicht viel.
Wie viele Prise sind da von Sie?
Pro Tag.
Das sind so vier bis fünf Stück vielleicht am Tag.
Entschuldigung, vier.
Vier bis fünf Stück am Tag.
Okay, das ist nicht so hoch.
Nein.
Die Prise sind einfach aufhören.
Ja, das Stress ist einfach zu groß.
Das habe ich immer wieder versucht, aber.
Und seit wann rauchen Sie?
Seit meiner Studentenzeit.
Also das ist schon die Weile her, seitdem ich vielleicht 20 bin.
Okay, und schinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja.
Was schinken Sie und wie oft schinken Sie?
Ja, einen Zucken und ein Bier oder ein Wein.
Wein trinke ich sehr gerne.
Zeiglich?
Ja.
Ein Gelass, zwei Gels.
Je nach Anlass, manchmal werden es auch mal zwei oder drei.
Das stimmt schon.
Und auch mehr?
Ja.
Ein Weiflöschchen.
Nein, das nur ab und zu machen.
Ja, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit den Vogeln?
Nehmen Sie nicht peinlich.
Das ist leider sehr bekannt.
Sie fragen Sachen natürlich, als Bürgermeister darf ich doch so was nicht sagen,
aber Sie unterliegen Ihre ärztlichen Schweigepflicht.
Natürlich haben wir sehr viel Stress und manchmal nehme ich da schon mal Sachen ein,
dass ich etwas ruhiger werde.
Was nehmen Sie?
Das will ich lieber nicht verraten.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben eine Weile, eine Allergie.
Ansonsten gibt es andere Allergie, oder?
Nein, das ist nicht bekannt.
Ich habe schon gefragt, wie das ist.
Wie äußert sich Ihre Allergie?
Ich bekomme dann immer einen starken Ausschlag.
Der Kreislauf beginnt abzufallen.
Das ist ganz schlimm.
Und ich bekomme schlecht Luft.
Okay.
Herr Weinhalt, auf meiner Seite habe ich eine wichtige Frage gesteilt.
Auf jeden Dank, was glauben Sie, was das ist?
Was ist das Problem?
Sie haben rechtzeitig mehr
Ansonsten gibt es aber nicht mehr.
Das kann ein Notfall sein.
Muss es jetzt operiert werden?
Zuerst gucken wir.
Wir wollen diese Diagnose rechtätig sein.
Wenn es nötig ist, sollen wir natürlich operieren.
Ich hoffe nicht, ich will nicht operieren.
Aber danach können wir noch mal besprechen.
Vielen Dank, Frau Doktor.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg.
Danke schön.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Kollegen noch Fragen?
Kein Fieber.
Wir haben noch nicht genau die Fragen.
Ich habe die Frage nicht ganz verstanden.
Sind die Schmerzen vom Ausgang auf einem anderen Ort gewandern?
Das wird im rechten Unterbau.
Ja.
Stahlen die Schmerzen in einem anderen Körperregion aus?
In die Leiste, hatte ich ja gesagt.
Gibt es, dass die Schmerzen dinden oder verstärkt?
Das war vor einer Stunde.
Als Pirin nicht geholfen hat, bin ich hergekommen.
Das, was Frau Doktor gegeben hat, hat ich hier geholfen.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Keine Ahnung, das kam mir plötzlich.
Haben Sie vorhin nicht zugeholfen?
Haben Sie als Vorarl-Krankheit Nirenstein?
Ja, das stimmt.
Das war aber auf der linken Seite.
Brauchen Sie oft Wasalassen?
Ja, das wusste ich schon, aber der Urlo gemeint, das kommt von meiner Prostata.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass ich in Ihrer Urin rote Farbe habe?
Nein, das war bisher nichts.
Wie gesagt, die Schmerzen sind erst vor einer Stunde aufgetreten.
Davor war alles in Ordnung.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Haben Sie am Anfang einmal ein Stuhlgang geholfen oder geholfen?
Nein, ich habe es nicht.
Ich habe die Winde geholfen, damit habe ich kein Problem.
Ein Stuhlgang war auch in Ordnung.
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Ja, ein bisschen schon.
Normalerweise gibt es einen Stuhlgang aus?
Nein, das kann ich ganz normal sagen.
Da hat ich bisher keine Sorgen.
Ist Ihre Schmerzen ein bisschen kraftig?
Ja, sind sehr starke Schmerzen.
Jetzt erst nach dem Medikament ist es etwas besser geworden.
Okay, ich glaube, es kommen immer die gleichen Fragen.
Ja, gleich.
Können wir am Tag gehen, als er die Zeit beregt, kehrt er.
Hallo, Oberalz, ich würde gerne einen neuen Patienten belegen.
Ah, Frau Göktasch, ja, guten Tag.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Schönen Tag.
Ja, Claus Weichheim ist ein 58-jähriger Patient.
Ah, ist es Gerhard Claus Weichel und so Oberwürger Meister?
Ja, ja, Oberwürger Meister.
Ich habe mir schon gerufen, Mensch.
Wenn ein Bürgermeister eine bekannte Person kommt,
müssen Sie mich sofort hochenden.
Das geht so nicht, Frau Dr.
Also, das nächste Mal noch passen.
Okay.
Ich wusste gar nicht, deswegen, aber ja, dann, ja.
Ja, das stimmt auch wieder, aber das hätten die Krankenschwestern Ihnen vielleicht sagen sollen, ne?
Ja, vielleicht.
Also, weil sowas möchte ich in Zukunft unterrichtet werden.
Okay.
Herr Weichheim ist ein 58-jähriger Patient.
Er ist 94 kg schwer und 1,85 m gross.
Ja, Sie wissen, er ist Oberwürger Meister und er, er hat sich heute wegen weit einer Stunde bestellen.
Eine Stunde bestellen, ne?
Einer, wegen seit einer, einer Stunde bestehenden.
Okay, einer Stunde bestellen, ne?
Okay, eine Stunde bestellen, das Bauchschmerzen, vorgestellt.
Seine Bauchschmerzen ist, wenn Sie vor mich unterstehen,
Auch die Schmerzen würden im leichten Bereich ausschützt werden.
Er hat auch Übelkeit, aber er habe noch nicht erbrochen.
Er hat sehr starke Schmerzen, deswegen haben wir zuerst die Farle Parameter überflügt.
Dann habe ich ein Schmerzmittel gegeben.
Dann alles war in Ordnung.
Er leitet an aktuelle Hebärzungen seit 6-8 Jahren.
Er hat eine Blutversperrte.
Anforderungen sind Kollespektome für 2 Jahre.
Familienanämnese sind unaufgänglich.
Vegetative Anämnese sind auch unaufgänglich.
Nur Schlafprobleme wegen Schmerzen.
Er nimmt regelmäßig Gemüse, aber in der Zeit des Lebens ist er nicht sehr weit.
Einmal täglich bei Begrüßung nimmt er Astridien.
Er ist raucher, trinkt regelmäßig Wein und Apfelblut.
Er ist eine Novagin allergiebekannt.
Anämnese und Klinik wurden am ehesten appendicitis hin.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen Illegos oder Nier und Stein in Betracht.
Sie haben vorhin gesagt, die Winde gehen gut ab.
Sie gehen von einer akuten Abbinde-Cidis aus.
Er hat schon die Nierensteine.
Ich würde gerne den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Sie können auch kippen oder überprüfen.
Er hat sehr starkes Schmerz.
Ich würde gerne den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Die Vertikulierung ist auf der linken Seite.
Ein Chronschub.
Ich habe nichts verstanden.
Das ist eine etatitiver Schmerz.
Das stimmt auch.